just four years before The Little
Mermaid Disney animation's most
ambitious project ever nearly destroyed
the entire Studio but like many other
80s bombs it found its audience years
later ishar had a lot going for it with
Warren batty and Dustin Hoffman
co-starring in what aim to be the next
Big Adventure movie the film was about
two talentless songwriters who traveled
to Morocco for a booking only to find
themselves caught up in a cold war
standoff unfortunately when Ishtar hit
theaters critics lambasted it as one of
the worst movies ever made it also cost
a ton initially ishar was budg Ed for
$28 million but the production ran into
numerous problems and the final cost was
a reported $51 million when the dust
settled disar made only $14.3 million at
the box office it didn't help that
Beverly Hills Cop 2 opened the same
weekend all but ensuring its failure
despite being a notorious bomb time has
aged ishar like a reasonably priced wine
you'd serve at a casual dinner party
critics have re-evaluated the film
praising it on its various re-releases
with Richard Brody of the New Yorker
saying the movie is among the most
original audacious and inventive movies
movies and funniest comedies of modern
times the 1980s was an excellent decade
for Fantasy films but not because they
made a ton of cash many that have since
been lauded as cult classics utterly
failed upon release like Crow an
ambitious mishmash of fantasy science
fiction and mythology genres croll tells
the tale of prince cwin who must recruit
a squad of Heroes to help on his quest
to rescue Prince Lisa from a fortress of
Alien Invaders these men follow no man
but me and I follow no man at all
would you follow a king coll failed to
woo audiences upon release and it bombed
pretty hard the estimated production
budget was around $47 million that's a
lot of money for a new intellectual
property costing the studio
significantly and ensuring no sequel
would see the light of day after it
returned just $16.9 million at the box
office today koll is a beloved Colt
classic and while it has its detractors
it also boasts a huge fan base the film
features then cuttingedge visual effects
and has a fantastic score by celebrating
composer James her so there's a lot for
people to like even though some
criticize croll for its slow pace Legend
is the Ridley Scott film most people
missed when it hit us theaters in 1985
it stars a young Tom Cruz a year before
he started in Top Gun Cruz plays Jack a
pure being who embarks on a quest to
stop the Lord of Darkness from covering
the world with Eternal Night Legend had
a lot of star power but critics weren't
kind to the story The Studio shelled out
$25 million for the film which only made
$23.5 million at the box office despite
the week box office though Legend earned
numerous technical accolades including
an Academy Award nomination for best
makeup it lost though few could look the
Lord of Darkness in the eyes and
realized Tim Curry was under all that
red paint Legend languished in cinematic
obscurity for years but Universal saved
it by releasing a director's cut DVD
restoring several cut scenes and the
original Jerry Goldsmith score Legend
was already a cult classic before the
2002 and subsequent 2011 re-release but
its popularity grew as more people
enjoyed the film for the first time the
first attempt at adapting Frank
Herbert's Dune for the big screen took
over a decade resulting in a film that
only somewhat resembles the book
accuracy was sacrificed for time when a
three-hour movie was cut and reshot down
to just over 2 hours dune follows the
same narrative structure as the novel
but incorporates elements utterly absent
from its source 1984's Dune was an
expensive film costing somewhere between
$4 to $42 million to produce but it made
only $3.9 million at the global box
office still while it failed in cinemas
Dune had a second life by a televised
broadcast and Home Video the expanded
1988 TV version included two parts
totally in 186 minutes but it wasn't
necessarily an improvement director
David Lynch was so disgusted with the
cut that he removed his name using the
pseudonyms of Alan Smithy for the
director and Judith booth for its Rider
ultimately Dune earned its fan base and
cult classic status from the home video
rental market while it's not the most
faithful adaptation of Herbert's work it
features beautifully imagined characters
places and themes the film's visual
style alone makes it a work of art and
despite its flaws it's beloved by many
try looking into that place where you
dare not look you'll find me there
staring back at you you mustn't
speak you may not know it but a film
starring Jeff goldbloom Gina Davis and
Jim Carrey hit theaters in 1989 and
completely bombed Earth Girls Are Easy
built around a song by Julie Brown is an
' 80s comedy about a valley girl who
befriends three furry aliens after their
spaceship crashes into her pool once
shaven the fuzzy aliens become
attractive men Earth girls or easy was
positively received by critics upon
release but hardly anyone bothered to
see it the film's estimated budget of
$10 million made the $3.9 million had
earned at the box office a tough pill to
swallow well most people missed out on
seeing Earth Girls Are Easy in theater
it blew up via the home rental market
and televised broadcasts Comedy Central
also aired the film throughout the '90s
and 2000s ensuring more people watched
it it's now settled nicely into the
realm of cult classics beloved for its
pure camp absurdity with multiple
musical numbers that show nobody took
anything too seriously making it an
enemy mind Humanity has been at war with
the Drax and it's a bitter fight starf
fighter pilot Willis davage hates the
draxx as much as anyone but when he and
an enemy pilot jerba both crash on a
hostile Planet they must learn to trust
one another to survive the story follows
these two enemies as they become
dependent on one another and ultimately
friends enemy mind is arguably one of
the greatest science fiction films ever
made that hardly anyone saw the film hit
theaters in 1985 after a number of
production issues and cost over runs
Enemy Mine was budgeted for $17 million
but ended up costing upwards of $48
million when it was finished the film
wasn't helped by middling critical
response and it also faced significant
competition at the Christmas Box Office
including Rocky 4 ultimately it only
made a poultry $12 million at the box
office making it a certified mega bomb
despite its obvious quality do you not
remember what you say p you maybe you
forgot what you said about Mickey Mouse
of all the zany movies produced in
the80s 1984 is the adventures of
buckaroo Bonsai across the eighth
Dimension has to be the strangest the
title is a mouthful and the film doesn't
hold back in throwing numerous Concepts
at the audience the hero is a
neurosurgeon physicist Rockstar and test
pilot who accesses the eighth Dimension
while testing a jet car through solid
matter bugaru banai is everything modern
Cinema isn't it's risky weird and a lot
of fun without any attempt at being
serious what's left is a cult classic
staring a ton of talent including John
litho Ellen Barkin Jeff gold Blum and
more but it was still a big flop ranai
cost 20th Century Fox $17 million to
make and it only managed to rake in
around $6.3 million despite this massive
loss of cash bucku bansai spawned a host
of spin-offs and other media including
Comics novels and even a video game
while the film is undoubtedly campy it's
a fun ride to the eighth Dimension any
sci-fi fan should see evil pure and
simple from the eighth
Dimension lady Hawk is a fantasy tale
centered around Matthew brk's thief the
mouse who busts out of a dungeon and
soon finds himself in involved in a
dangerous plot to hunt down a legendary
warrior in his one true lady love the
mouse is out for himself initially but
eventually becomes a hero of his own
story the film came out shortly after
war games and just before Ferris bu's
day off so brck was something of a
rising star at the time unfortunately
almost nobody bothered to watch his
foray into the fantasy genre in theaters
the studio shelled out about $20 million
for lady Hawk and only saw a return of
$1 18.4 million in ticket sales the film
passed Into Obscurity for a while and
only managed to claw out with broad's
increased Fame despite failing to Garner
much attention from audiences upon
release lady Hawk received two Academy
Award nominations and won the Saturn
Award for best fantasy film these days
it's remembered for its excellent
characters Rich sound and exceptionally
well-written romance typically lacking
in fantasy films animation in the early
1980s often delivered outstanding films
many of which didn't earn much money at
the box office this was often due to an
expanding Market of adult-oriented
Animation in conflict with more
traditional cartoon films for children
for instance Ralph baki's movies often
struggle to woo audiences upon release
only to become cult classics discovered
in the home rental market a great
example of this is 1981's American pop
the film follows four generations of an
immigrant family filled with musicians
each generation tells the tale of their
American journey as they navigate The
Perils of history's most significant
events including the Great War World War
II the Civil Rights Movement
counterculture and more like most of
baki's Works American pop features a mix
of Animation Styles and archival
liveaction footage American pop was a
relatively expensive film cross in
approximately $5 million to produce
unfortunately it only made $6 million at
the box office barely scraping even
American pop has gained a wider audience
as a cult classic and offers an
exceptional and eclectic amalgamation of
20th Century Music the soundtrack caused
a lot of Rights issues though so the
film didn't come out on VHS until
1998 explorers is one of those movies
that if you saw it as a kid you
absolutely loved it it's a
quintessential kids movie about a group
of teens who discover a means of flying
into space they meet some aliens have a
taste of Venture and become better
friends by the end explorers suffered a
fate common to many sleeper hits the
competition killed it when it was
released in July 1985 Back to the Future
was in its second week in theaters
ensuring nobody dropped a few bucks to
see the latest Joe Dante film explorers
also fought for ticket sales Against The
Goonies which was released a month prior
but was still dominating the box office
and a re-release of ET as a result
explorers had a poor showing at the box
office earning just shy of $10 million
the film features numerous special
effect shots that ended up costing
Paramount pitches $24 million making
explorers a genuine box office bomb many
eventually discovered it on VHS though
ensuring it achieved cult classic status
Highlander follows the unending life of
Connor McLoud a 16th century Warrior
from the Scottish Highlands a monster of
a man called kran kills him in his first
battle in 1536 but instead of rotting he
wakes up as good as new Connor is an
immortal a group of people who can only
die via decapitation The Immortals are
eventually drawn to a particular place
where they must kill each other for the
right to gain power beyond mortal
understanding it's an unusual premise
but it makes for an exceptional fantasy
action adventure flick that was also
unfortunately a flop Highlander cost $16
million to make and it only earned $12.9
million at the box office when it
debuted in 1986 despite this the film
gained a significant following and it
became a multimedia franchise consisting
of multiple terrible sequels a popular
television series a possible reboot
starring Henry Cavell and one very
famous catchphrase there can be only one
Highlander is a fantastic film for many
reasons one of which is its spectacular
soundtrack Queen provided numerous
tracks for the film including who wants
to live forever a kind of magic and
princes of the universe which open the
TV series title
sequence in Big Trouble in Little China
truck driver Jack Burton finds himself
in San Francisco's Chinatown where he's
pulled into a magical plot to help save
two women from an immortal demon named
David Lan it's incredibly violent and
over the top there are monsters martial
arts magic and more which is exactly
what you want wants in a John Carpenter
film the film was expensive requiring
extensive visual effects elaborate
costumes and tons of makeup it cost
around $25 million to produce but Big
Trouble in Little China only pulled in
about $1.2 million at the box office
most critics didn't tear it apart and
the film garnered some positive
attention but it fell victim to the
plethora of excellent movies showing in
theaters when it dropped in July 1986
Big Trouble in Little China hit theaters
alongside the Karate Kid Park 2 Top Gun
aliens Ferris feler day off and more
competition may have killed its earnings
upon release but these days Big Trouble
in Little China is a widely beloved cult
classic when Jim Henson and George Lucas
worked together they produced plenty of
wonderful content but fans didn't always
appreciate their work at the time
Labyrinth is one such film and it's
truly surprising it didn't do well the
film follows Sarah played by a young
Jennifer Connelly as she fights to
rescue her baby brother from the Goblin
King played by David Bowie who holds him
in his castle at the center of an
otherworldly Labyrinth Boe provided much
of the film's music and dominated every
scene he was in hence since work shines
through the many adorable and
frightening puppets appearing in nearly
every scene it's a true Gothic fairy
tale adventure film and it's magical but
sadly it bombed Labyrinth cost $25
million to make and audiences avoided it
referring to see Top Gun or any of the
other better performing films released
in June
1986 despite tons of star power behind
it the film only took $14.5 million at
the global box office Labyrinth became a
hit by the Home Video Market though and
these days fans adore it as a cult
classic decades after its release
Labyrinth has expanded into a franchise
consisting of comics board games books
and
more the 1980s were a good decade for
Fantasy films and you can't have a
proper movie in the genre without a
Dragon Enter Dragon Slayer a dark
fantasy about a young wizard named Galen
Brad Warden who embarks on a quest to
slay the dragon vermithrax a
400-year-old beast only saded by virgin
sacrifice much of the story details
galen's Adventure which climaxes as he
fulfills the title and becomes a hero
dragon slayer features numerous creature
effect shots and holds it distinction of
being the first non- luucas film project
to utilize industrial Light and magic
for its visual effects work the film was
relatively expensive to produce it cost
Paramount Pictures $18 million to bring
dragon slayer to life on the Silver
Screen the movie's box office earnings
of between $6 million and $14 million
ensured Dragon slayer's failure still
despite being a financial flop in
theaters dragon slayer earned Academy
Award nominations for Best music and
best effects and fans of dragon movies
have long considered it among the best
of the genre while more recent fantasy
films are maybe more refined dragon
slayer is an excellent entry from the
1980s and for a long time it was
arguably the best dragon movie to hit
theaters for decades The Adventures of
Baron mowen is one of Terry gilliam's
most ambitious films it involved three
countries co-producing the Epic tale
about an 18 century nobleman's exploits
fighting against the Ottoman Empire most
of the Monty Python crew worked
alongside Robin Williams and many more
stars to bring the film to life and it's
as magnificent as a title suggests
Columbia Pictures paid $ 46.6 million to
produce the film that's a sizable
investment and it was nearly double the
film's initial $23.5 million budget
stories of a nightmare shoot and issues
with the studio likely contributed to
minuscule ticket sales and the film
ended up earning just $8 million at the
box office making it a true financial
disaster I remember the effects I don't
really I never got any feeling for the
people involv the failure of The
Adventures of Baron munen doesn't make
much sense in hindsight it received
mostly positive reviews and nominations
for four Academy Awards the people who
watched it loved the movie and it's not
so much a cult classic today as it's a
beloved conclusion to gilliam's Trilogy
of imagination featuring Robin Williams
as a hilariously over-the-top King of
the Moon in 1981 John travolto starred
in Brian dep's blowout a neo- Noir
Thriller that had a lot going for it the
film follows Jack Terry a movie sound
effects Tech who inadvertently records
evidence of the assassination of a
presidential hopeful disguised as an
automobile accident this thrust him into
an adventure rif with danger and
political Intrigue although that sounds
like the perfect recipe for a success
successful Thriller 1981 audiences
avoided blowout the film cost the studio
around $18 million to produce but with
little interest driving audiences to the
theater is it only made $13.7 million
the likely reason for its downfall was
poor Word of Mouth from the Scamp few
who bothered to see it the film has a
dark ending and filmmakers always take a
gamble when they conclude a movie on a
down note still it remains one of dma's
best early films Heathers is about
Veronica Sawyer and a click of popular
girls in high school all three of whom
are named Veronica is something of an
outsider and she falls for a bad boy JD
the film plays out much like mean girls
but with much more murder and multiple
fake suicides capped off with a bomb
exploding at a high school it's a dark
comedy to be sure despite the tongue and
cheat critique of its many controversial
issues or possibly because of it
Heathers wasn't a hit on release Roger
Ebert gave the film two and a half Stars
touting its message while pointing out
the difficulty some may have an
understanding its point of view he wrote
is this a black comedy about murder or
just a cynical moral play I can't
believe
it I just killed my best friend and your
worst enemy same difference Heathers
only cost around $3 million to make
despite this it lost money pulling in
only $1.1 million in ticket sales still
Heathers has stood the test of time and
despite its controversial depiction of
high school murder it remains popular to
this day his since spawned a musical and
a television reboot that premiered in
2018 although Martin scores he's
directorial efforts are universally
praised his box office receipts haven't
always been nearly as consistent the
king of comedy follows an aspiring
stand-up comedian played by Robert dairo
who becomes obsessed with a veteran
comic played by Jerry Lewis he believes
they are true friends but in reality
he's a little more than a stalker things
come to a head when he kidnaps his Idol
to land a spot opening for a show and it
all ends with massive success for a
short time the film though didn't have
as much success for any amount of time
despite all the star power and critical
accolades a king of comedy was in and
out of theaters without earning anywhere
near its $19 million budget the movie
brought in just over $2.5 million at the
worldwide box office solidifying it as a
box office bomb time has only helped the
film gain an audience though with
reviewers promoting it decades later
Mark KMOD to the guardian called it
scorsese's greatest film legendary
Japanese director Akira kurasawa named
the king of comedy one of his favorite
films and the 2019 box office smashit
Joker Drew on the king of comedy as a
primary
influence Blade Runner is considered one
of the greatest science fiction films of
all time time so it may be a surprise to
some to learn that it was a box office
failure but it's true the 1982 film
follows Rick Deckard as he hunts down
and retires a group of renegade Nexus 6
replicants on Earth his investigations
take him throughout Los Angeles where he
uncovers more than he planned in his
hunt for the leader of the replicants
Roy baty Blade Runner was an ambitious
project requiring numerous visual effect
shots all the effects in the film were
created without the benefit of CGI and
they still hold up today map paintings
models and more came together to bring
the world of 2019 Los Angeles to life
and in the end the studio paid $28
million to produce Blade Runner but on
its initial release Blade Runner only
brought in $27.5 million failing to even
make the break even Point since then the
film has been re-released numerous times
eventually pushing its total into the
black and it spawned a critically
acclaimed sequel in 2017 safe to say
that despite its disappointing returns
at the box office Blade Runner hasn't
yet disappeared like tears and rain all
those moments will be lost
in
time the right stuff details the US
military test pilots who developed and
operated various vehicles in the
burgeoning space program and continues
to show the development of NASA and the
first wave of astronauts known as the
Mercury 7 the film is an epic running
for nearly 200 minutes as it explores
the dawn of the Space Race ending with
the conclusion of the Mercury program
the right Stu cost $27 million to
produce but its ticket sales only
amounted to $21.5 million with its
extremely long runtime likely scaring
away many viewers Roger eert gave the
film four stars naming it the best movie
of the year while it didn't make much
money The Right Stuff nabbed eight
Academy Award nominations winning four
in technical categories including best
music sound sound effects and editing
it's one of those films almost everyone
agrees is fantastic despite its failure
upon release it's rare that a Disney
movie doesn't do well but it's not
unheard of case in point the Black
Cauldron in 1985 after 48 years of
producing one hit after another Walt
Disney Animation Studios dro a serious
bomb the film follows a young hero and
his friends as they seek to stop the
horned King from obtaining the titular
Black Cauldron so he can take over the
world it's a dark fantasy that
legitimately frightened children when it
was released in theaters that's not
something Disney likes to do so the
studio slapped it with its first PG
rating despite removing several scenes
the Final Cut Is Still terrifying thanks
to an army of skeletal zombie Warriors
The Black Cauldron was the most
expensive animated film ever made at the
time at $44 million and it only made
21.2 $ million at the global box office
significantly damaging the animation
studio stability fortunately Disney
Animation survived the Black Cauldron
but the film almost didn't it took 13
years for Disney to open the vault and
release the Black Cauldron on VHS
perhaps because of the prior
unavailability the film didn't take long
to build a fan base and The Black
Cauldron has become one of Disney
animation's few cult
[Music]
classics